hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at the render
on render commands renderer API stuff
like that how we can actually kind of
like begin beginning and our rendering
and submit geometry and meshes and stuff
like that in between definitely check
out that video if you haven't already
and today we're gonna be talking about
cameras cameras are a pretty big topic
and they're I think something that is
both like extremely vile for you to know
but also extremely like important that
you consider the architecture of cameras
and how they work properly and in order
to actually consider how to architect a
proper kind of I guess camera system in
your actual game engine you need to
actually know how rendering works but
not only the rendering side of things
but also kind of the gameplay side of
things because cameras are interesting
they're vital for rendering you
absolutely need to have a good camera
system if you want to render anything on
your screen and also of course you know
that with as with rendering you know you
want to make that as optimal as possible
because if you can optimize your
rendering it means you can have more
things on the screen and just more time
more kind of actual kind of I guess you
can have more but I was gonna say like a
higher price essentially right because
we can't refer to like something being
expensive or cheap as to kind of how how
much time it takes and what we're kind
of paying with is our time right because
we have a finite kind of amount of time
in which to render a frame so if you can
kind of make you a rendering as
efficient as possible you can render
more things on the screen and that's
obviously very very useful and buy more
things on the screen I don't necessarily
mean like more objects on the same I
just mean kind of you can spend more of
your time doing rendering right and more
kind of in frame time and that's really
really important to actually producing
high fidelity graphics now there's also
the gameplay side of things there right
because whilst you need cameras for
rendering a lot of the time cameras
respond to your actual interaction with
the game right so user input and stuff
like that if I kind of move my character
around chances are is probably going to
move the camera and so because we kind
of have that twofold relationship where
it's influenced by both the gameplay but
then also important to be submitted for
rendering the architecture of it is
actually a lot more important than you
might think and so because of that what
we're actually going to do today
we're just gonna focus on planning and
when deciding to do this video like I
was very tempted to just kind of just go
into the code and just write a little
kind of explain how cameras gonna work
and actually come up with like an
orthographic camera or something for our
kind of 2d scene at the moment and then
just kind of you know push that in and
actually have that code ready but I
thought it would be a much better idea
for me to kind of just spend today just
actually drawing like diagrams for you
guys talking about how cameras work and
all that and how we're gonna set them up
and hazel and what the kind of be a
scale plan is not just what we're gonna
do like immediately now to get this
thing up and running in its kind of
first iteration the other benefit of
this tour apart from just you guys
having more of a holistic kind of
understanding of camera systems is what
I want you to do is after this video
right go ahead and try and do it
yourself you have the source code to
hazel on the public github repository
right go ahead and just try and take out
all the information that we've talked
about today and write this camera system
based on my guidance yourself right you
might even get some other ideas along
the way in which to make this camera
system even better than what I'm gonna
just kind of plan out here right so I
really encourage you guys to do that
because if just fall if you're following
along with this video so just going to
get hub and get getting the source code
and then just like changing you know
hazel to your engine name and that's it
you're not really getting anything out
of this so I would really encourage you
guys to do that and we also thank all
the patrons that made this series
possible patron Ocampo slash the chatter
is where you can go to help support this
series you'll get access to source code
that I've written already for kind of my
version of hazel which is like you know
full kind of 3d scene and with a PBR
renderer and all that kind of fun stuff
and obviously that's got like a full 3d
camera system in it and everything so
you can kind of see how that works
and then you also get videos like a week
early as well anyway jumping back to
cameras so let's just go ahead and go to
the drawing board and actually kind of I
guess theorize or talk about how a basic
camera systems gonna work and in fact
maybe before we go to the drawing board
I'll just have a go kind of explaining
it and then I can't draw you guys more
of the architecture so cameras
essentially what we want to do is think
about what cameras are used for right so
what I like to do when I
about any kind of concept right because
cameras are just a concept there's no
such thing as a camera in OpenGL right
so you have to think about what a camera
actually is right
so camera is used for first of all
defining I guess how we look on to a
scene and I'm gonna kind of talk about
3d cat 3d cameras in this the same
obviously applies to tweedy but it's
just I think it's just a bit more like
real world and like real cameras in the
real world and it's just might be easier
and also more powerful to think about
cameras and kind of a 3d context then it
would encounter just a 2d context
because 2d cameras are usually quite
easy to kind of do and obviously Hazel's
gonna be a 3d engine so when you think
about it in that kind of context um but
essentially cameras provided a means for
us to view into the world right so we
have a bunch of objects in our 3d scene
and what we want to do is look at them
from a particular viewpoint right and
not just from a particular viewpoint but
I guess in a certain format as well so
what I mean by that is like just like in
the real world you can take a camera and
you can put any kind of lens on that
right like you could have like a really
wide like 10 millimeter lens or
something like that or you could have
like a really zoomed in like 200 mil
right um want to see if you're not a
photographer or a videographer you might
understand how these times work but
hopefully fluid ah that student kind of
kind of makes sense right you can you
have different focal lengths and in the
same way that's what we kind of have in
a you know kind of game engine as well
right now we can refer them as field of
view rather than actual focal lengths
also although if you do actually create
a physical camera system which you can
do of course and we might explore that
in the future and Hazel because I'm I'm
quite you know I would love to kind of
go down the photo Road photorealistic
path
um in terms of rendering for hazel
anyway if we do that um aside from that
it's usually in field of view right so
field of view is kind of like how wide
or narrow our field of view is right so
how much we can actually see you put a
camera here but how like how wide is the
camera right how much can we actually
see of the scene because just having a
position of the camera and like an
orientation of the camera is all great
but we need to still know how much we
can see and like you know if I was to
destroy a quick diagram for you you know
if you imagine that this box over here
is
like the camera right we have a field of
view that could be quite wide which
means that if we have you know a cube
and it's kinda like a top-down view or a
sphere or something like that we can see
both of them or the field of view could
be quite narrow like this and that would
mean that you can see that we kind of
clip through the cube and we clip
through the sphere so we could have
something like that right but this kind
of field of view is known as fourth
right and it's basically usually given
in like either degrees or radians
because we're humans we like dealing
with degrees more so usually we'd say
like a field of view of like 45 degrees
or 65 degrees or 90 degrees or something
insane like that right
so usually you probably want to render
at about 45 maybe like 45 to 65 is
probably an acceptable range anything
higher than that and you'll start to see
quite a lot of distortion around the
edges same as what you would with like a
fisheye lens or even just like a I mean
even if you get like a fairly wide like
12 millimeter lens on like a full-frame
sensor in the real world and you look at
the edges of your frame and you try and
take a like a photo of someone's face
but like they're like over here in your
frame you'll see that they actually end
up being quite distorted and it can look
quite funny so that's why we generally
want to render kind of in this range but
the idea is that's kind of what a
camera's made up of right it's not just
made up of a position like you know if
this is like our scene you know this has
like an X Y Z coordinate alright and
then probably like a rotation as well
which you could give in X Y Z as well if
it was like Euler rotations or you can
use quaternions which is you know what
we're gonna use and what you should
probably use it's not just that right so
it's not just a transform right it's
also other physical kind of camera
properties like the field of view right
there's also an aspect ratio that's
usually given right and an aspect ratio
is just going to basically determine
kind of you know if the camera should
render like this if it around like that
how wide is it gonna be because that's
gonna be really important as well so
that we can actually fit this properly
into our frame buffer and you know when
we've kind of rented to our screen or
render into a texture so all of these
kind of properties define what a camera
is and that's kind of really important
to understand so when I don't underst
a concept or when I'm kind of talking
about a new kind of concept right so
cameras like what cameras I don't know
what they are I don't know how they go
work in my game engine the best thing to
do is this right break it down into data
what actual data is this data American
welcome what kind of data is a camera
like what am I actually doing you know
but I ran that when I break things down
to actual OpenGL calls what data do I
need to take from my camera and pass
into like graphics rendering territory
right and in this case as I said I'm
going to need the actual position of the
camera somewhere in the world and the
orientation of the camera and then
actual kind of like the properties of
the camera not just kind of the
transform but also the field of view and
the aspect ratio now let's break that
down even further what does it mean to
have a camera in OpenGL right like what
is actually main like because there's no
concept of cameras in OpenGL how two
cameras actually work well what happens
is a camera is really you know let's we
won't talk about filter view we want to
talk about aspect ratio let's talk about
the transform of camera so it's where
the camera is in our 3d world and where
it's looking towards where it's kind of
pointing towards right what does that
actually do and what does that mean so
if I have a cube in my scene is at the
origin and is here and I move the camera
kind of up and it's going to look at it
right the thing that's actually moving
and the thing that we actually want to
do is render the cube at a different
position in our screen right as I
dragged the camera up if I start here
and I driving the camera up right what's
actually happening is the cube is moving
from here to here right I'm suddenly
looking at the cube kind of clock down
and again if I draw you a diagram you
know we might start with the cube being
in the middle of the stream right but
then as the camera as the actual like
camera which I'll mark with the C moves
upwards what's actually gonna happen is
that cube is suddenly going to be more
like this you know kind of you know view
right depending on kind of how you
render it I guess right but basically
what's gonna happen is and if you get my
awful drawing but we're just gonna look
at the cube more like this yeah we're
gonna see the top face a bit more all
right because that camera's moved
so if you think about what's actually
changed on our screen it's the it's kind
of the transform of the cube right the
cube has gone from us looking at the
front face to us kind of looking at the
kind of both the front and the top face
so the cube it looks like the cube is
kind of rotated a bit and again if we
decide that we want to move our camera
back if I just undo like all of this um
if we decide that we actually want to
move our camera back right what actually
happens right that's how I did all that
one move but anyway what actually
happens when we move our camera back
well the cube might be you know this big
because we're looking at it flat on and
then if we kind of just wheel that
camera back right it's gonna suddenly be
smaller right so what's actually
changing on the screen well the cube is
the scale of the cube seems to be
changing it seems to be getting smaller
so what I'm gonna try to get your heads
is that the cameras don't exist right
what actually happens is based on the
kind of made up transform of our camera
we want to change the transform of our
entire scene and it's important that you
think about it as not kind of a per
object basis but really it's the whole
scene right if I have three cubes in my
scene and I move the camera back does
one of the cubes gets more known all of
the cubes get smaller because I'm going
backwards with my camera right so
cameras affect the whole scene when you
kind of you know last last episode we
learn about begin saying and scene right
so when we begin a scene that's why we
push a camera and that's why I mentioned
that in the previous video because when
we begin a scene we push a camera for
that same why because when I'm start
rendering a scene it's all gonna be
rendered from that one perspective you
know you walk into a room in real life
with your camera you take a photo of
everything right everything in that
seeing that you take a photo of it's
gonna be taken from that one people now
obviously if you talk about more
advanced rendering and where we might
want to do additional passes or even
additional passes with different camera
orientations for example we might need
to render a depth buffer like for a
shadow map or we might need to render
like a dynamic cube map reflection or
something like that that doesn't matter
right we're not talking about those kind
of cameras we're talking about our main
same camera we have exactly one of those
right so like every scenario and it's
gonna be at a particular orientation
every single object that we ran
in our scene is gonna be from that
actual like position in 3-space right so
basically what I'm saying is that that
transform of the camera right we want to
move our objects by that transform now
here's another cool question like the
dis right we can see that if we move our
camera back we want the object to get
smaller right I mean it's not we don't
want to actually change the scale of the
object effectively that is what had that
that's what happens if you're dealing
with like a perspective projection right
objects that are further away I rendered
smaller but what's actually happening is
what's moving the object further away so
when we move the camera back the object
it were basically moving the object
further away when we move the camera
forward we're moving the object closer
so it looks like it's kind of inverted
right what happens if we have our camera
and we move the camera left well let's
take a look if we have our camera let's
say this is our kind of camera view over
here right if we move this camera left
right so I'm moving this whole this
actual outer kind of rectangle left the
cameras gonna end up here right so
what's actually happened this cube this
cube is effectively moved right because
now the view is like this right so
moving the camera left who's that right
yeah what about what about rotation
right so what if I kind of tilt the
camera forward
well this object's gonna move that way
and it's gonna kind of change but the
thing is the object isn't gonna rotate
around itself right the object is gonna
rotate around effectively like the
origin of the world but not really right
this is a bit difficult to think about
and that's why also you know if the
object was in the origin of the world
and effectively yeah like the object
would just rotate but if it if it's
offset by some kind of position like so
it's got its own own kind of position in
the world and it's not centered around
the origin effectively what's gonna
happen is it's gonna like it might
rotate like it's gonna rotate completely
differently so I'm just gonna rotate
about itself it's gonna actually move as
well as kind of rotate but that's a more
advanced topic we're really Durning to
discuss how that actually works because
it will just work if you do your maths
properly and we'll
see that in action in the future so
effectively what I'm saying is that
everything is kind of inverted right so
whenever we move our camera left all the
objects now seem move right we take the
transform of all of the objects in our
scene and we transform them so that they
move the opposite way right so this kind
of data that defines where the camera's
transform is is a matrix right it's a
transformation matrix and specifically
we refer to it as the view matrix why
because it's kind of like our view into
the same some people call like the I
matrix because it's like our eye looking
into the same but I like calling it a
view matrix which is also very popular
term for it so this a view matrix what
we do and that's the transform of the
actual camera just by itself right if we
just take the view matrix which again is
a transform of where the camera is in 3d
space that's what it is it's just the
kind of the transform of the camera in
3d space so where is it the translation
right so we're actually is it what kind
of XYZ coordinate in our scene is the
camera at and then the orientation like
the rotation matrix that's essentially
where the camera is actually oriented
that's the location of the camera
however what we want to do when we
actually render from the cameras point
of view and we need to transform our
objects is we can't just transform them
by the cameras matrix right by the
cameras view matrix that doesn't make
any sense because what we're supposed to
do is move the objects not in the same
kind of way right but in the opposite
way so what we actually need to do is
invert the matrix we need to take that
cameras view matrix and just invert it
right a few ways you could do that you
can actually do that manually just by
kind of negating things from the no in
other words if I want to move my camera
- let's just say X Y that is equal to
five so five five five right it's my X
players therefore my camera I can just
do negative five five five right
negative five negative 5 negative five I
can kind of manually invert it but
usually what you would do is you'll
calculate the TRS transform rotation
scale cameras user than have don't have
scale so you don't have to worry about
that
translation times rotation and then you
take that matrix and you invert it and
that is actually kind of the
transformation you will be applying to
all of the objects in your scene
and that's really as simple as it is so
what I've talked about so far has just
been the data right at that
how we get the data what we do is we
take the camera we position it somewhere
in 3d space we give it an orientation
right we get that matrix we construct
like a transformation matrix out of
those two things the position and the
route and the rotation right the
orientation and then we invert it and
that matrix is what we take and we
transform all of our objects by and now
what about the field of view and the
aspect ratio that's like how does that
how is that even stored the way that's
stored is in something called a
projection matrix specifically for a 3d
scene and for that field of view and
aspect ratio it's something called a
perspective matrix which basically
defines a certain projection loosely
like really it's a projection which
objects that are further away have like
the perspective effect right so they're
smaller right we have that kind of
vanishing point that kind of idea of
just you know having like if I just move
down here I'm just kind of having this
kind of you know if you look like like a
street and you look at something like
this right where you know you have like
a bunch of you might have like a bunch
of buildings here or whatever here's a
door like there's a door you kind of
have that vanishing point where
eventually everything kind of just goes
into this kind of and I gotta stop doing
that everything kind of just goes into
this kind of vanishing point in the end
right and that's kind of what you end up
with so this is kind of a perspective
projection there's also something called
an orthographic projection usually those
use for 2d rendering and in that kind of
scenario objects that are further away
don't actually get smaller so in other
words if I am rendering a cube right and
it looks like this and I render a cube
that's like a lot like far away kind of
behind this cube and a bit off to the
right in a perspective projection it
would look like this whereas in an
orthographic projection there would be
like the same size they look like this
even though this one's a lot further
away okay so we have different kind of
projection matrices I mean that's stored
as a matrix so this field of view and an
aspect ratio kind of all this kind of
stuff right
that's stuff is stored inside a
projection matrix specifically a
perspective matrix and since we're using
GLM we can just construct one of those
by just saying GL em you know
perspective right and that will create a
perspective matrix for us and then we
can actually I think there's a function
called perspective of and then we can
provide the field of
you and aspect ratio and everything will
kind of weekend I think we can even
provide a width and height of our actual
frame buffer and we'll kind of do the
intervention itself essentially to come
up with the aspect ratio and that it
needs and all of that and that just
returns to us a four by four matrix so a
matte form okay now the cameras
transform as I mentioned X Y Z and X Y
Zed like ever take a transform you know
being the position in the rotation
that's also stored in the view matrix
which is also a matte form and then
obviously the transform of our object
and 3d scene is also a matrix so that's
TRS translation rotation scale all of
that is stored in a matrix as well which
is a transformation matrix and then
finally we have the actual vertices of
the tree of the 3d model now I am
getting a bit ahead of myself because we
haven't covered any of this really but
we will in the future is providing some
context so basically what we end up with
is a bunch of matrices and in order to
actually figure out where our where our
objects should be on our like inside our
screen right we need to essentially
multiply all of those matrices together
so what we do is we take the perspective
matrix right so we have our projection
matrix we multiply that with our view
matrix right and then we multiply that
with our model matrix which is also
known as the world matrix which is
essentially the matrix of our models so
it's like kind of like this we have this
cube that's the transformation matrix of
the cube right and then that will also
eventually be multiplied by our actual
vertex positions okay and that is what
gives us the full picture of where our
actual model needs to be rendered in our
screen and obviously if it lies outside
of the screen it they'll just be clipped
it'll be cold okay so that's what we end
up with now this this order is GLM's
order and also the order of
multiplication that we see in GLSL
shaders because they're column-major in
DirectX this is the other way around so
you basically you have your vertex
position right you multiply that with
the model matrix right you multiply that
with the view matrix and your model you
multiply that with the projection matrix
okay so it's the other way around
because it's a row major and obviously
by the way M like four by four matrix
multiplication matters may be in fact
matrix multiplication order
matters okay so make sure you do it in
the right way and that's why I keep
saying TRS because we want to multiply
translation we want to do translation
times rotation time scale to combine all
of our matrices together doing them in
reverse order gives you a different
matrix okay so that's pretty much it
that is that's all the data that you
actually need right we've spent a lot of
this episode actually talking about data
which i think is good because that's
what it boils down to right I want you
guys to realize that we're building in
game end and it's fairly complicated but
at the end of the day we're just dealing
with numbers these are just matrices
right they will eventually make their
way into the appropriate graphics
rendering pipeline areas and that's what
actually allows us to render graphics a
particular place on the screen in this
scenario
okay so enough about data I think that
makes sense hopefully that's enough for
you guys to go on and actually make your
own camera system that maybe deals with
these kind of matrices and all that now
let's talk about how the API works so we
have this data fantastic you know my
cube has a model matrix which is a
transformation matrix that defines where
it's going to be in the world you know
it's obviously got a bunch of vertices
so I've got my vertex positions I've got
a camera which has a view matrix right
great and the camera also has a
Britisher matrix pH metrics defines like
the field of view and kind of how it
looks into the world view matrix defines
where it is in the world and where it's
looking right I've got that so in other
words the part that actually belongs to
the camera just to reiterate is the
projection and the view okay model is
actually on the object and vertex
position is actually on like the mesh
right so the projection view on the
camera right I've got that what do I do
with that data so essentially what we
need to do at some point is do this
whole multiplication that I've just
mentioned right we have this projection
times view x model times vertex position
projection and view we can just do that
multiplication in the camera it's you
know that there are a lot of cases in
which you will need for example just the
camera position right not even the
rotation but I just need to know where
the position is that's important for
when you're trying to calculate a
vectors between like a particular pixel
and the cameras like view
position you know for things like
lighting calculations but just for
rendering a cube on the screen which is
what we're doing right now you you don't
actually need these to be separated you
can just multiply it and that's it
that's kind of your camera matrix draw
and you'd probably call that something
like VP or you know PV usually you'd
call it V pages because that's kind of
the UM whoops I meant to do this that's
kind of the directx way of doing things
but the view the view projection matrix
is just projection x view in OpenGL so
you have that and you can kind of just
use that but the model matrix obviously
comes from the object so if I render
three objects in my scene that's gonna
be three different model matrices right
so I can't just kind of bake this in
right I can do this like once per scene
when I move my camera and I've decided
that it's gonna be in this particular
place once the frame is what I meant to
say I can just bake this kind of I can
just do this multiplication done right
every single thing that I render is
gonna be with this matrix Y because
again I've entered my scene I've started
in a new scene right the cameras not
going to move throughout rendering a
scene right when you take a photo no
object moves right you kind of have the
position of it as in the camera doesn't
move while you take a photo right you've
taken a photo that's it as a snapshot of
the scene from that point of view so
this stuff is static right doesn't
change but then the model matrix is
going to be the transform of each object
that does change right and because that
changes and because you know you have
three cubes you render them at different
positions right you can't kind of do
this multiplication just then and there
right it kind of needs to be done for
each object and then finally this vertex
position obviously is also kind of done
you know for each object as well because
obviously objects have unique vertices
and they only belong belong to a kind of
one mesh so anyway what I'm trying to
say is that um we have this VP matrix
that's fantastic but then we have to do
this model matrix which comes from the
actual object itself that's why the
camera is part of the same right and
that's why we submit it when we begin a
scene because we're saying we're
beginning a scene with this point of
view now when we render the object does
a few ways to do this trend this kind of
transformation we could actually
technically speaking do it
in C++ right so we could say that we've
got the VP matrix right let's just go
down here and maybe over here where
we've got some more space so we have the
VP matrix we're going to multiply it
with the model matrix right where do we
do this
so we could do this in c++ land but then
what we would need to do is actually
multiply it do this kind of
multiplication for every single model
right that's good and that's probably
something you'll have to do unless you
you know use batching or some kind of
other you know instancing in which you
probably have like an array of these
matrices there's a few different ways to
do it but it's essentially you have the
opportunity to do this in c++ which
means that you kind of do this
multiplication and then into your shader
which is where you do the matrix times
vertex kind of multiplication right so
this kind of last step is traditionally
done this kind of last step is always
done really in the vertex shader no
that's what we've kind of been doing but
just in a different way because that's
essentially the result of this is what
we output into GL position right which
is inside our vertex shader okay the
result of this whole multiplication so
all of that stuff right we can do in
like this
MVP matrix that we end up with we
basically take we can take that and we
can multiply that by our vertex
positions inside the actual vertex
shader
and that's our GL position so you can do
that or you can do even this
multiplication in the shader and then
you kind of just end up with instead of
this you know you just do VP times model
times vertex right and I can't really
tell you what the best thing to do is
the obvious advantage of doing it in C++
means that you don't have to do it for
every vertex so a vertex shader runs for
every vertex so if you do it in your
vertex shader it's going to use
multiplication per vertex which may or
may not be worse right however if you do
in C++ it's kind of done per object
that's why we also don't want to do like
a projection times a few times model
because the British and view stuff we
can just rather do once in C++ for our
entire scene and then keep using that
data rather than having to actually kind
of do that
you know vertex which is what we would
have to do if we were in the vertex
shader so anyway um so between these two
um it depends on your setup a lot of the
time you need this model matrix anyway
for example if you want to translate you
know normals into like world space or
something like that you know you'll need
the rotation of the model right not that
not that translation really but the
rotation of the model so this matrix
does come in handy as does this as does
potentially the inverse of this there's
a lot of different things that are
important right so typically I end up
doing something like this in my shader
right where I have the V projection
which is my camera I have the model
which is the transform of my model right
of my object and then I have obviously
the vertex data which comes in in the
attributes okay so that's kind of what
we end up with so to summarize what we
need to do is when we begin our scene
right and now we're getting into actual
code when we begin our scene we want to
submit this view projection matrix and
that's why we begin our scene with a
camera as a parameter because we need to
begin a scene with the camera again if
we had an environment and like a light
kind of setup or something like that
like a bunch of lights we also submit
those but we don't right now but we're
gonna have a camera that's what we're
talking about now so we can submit a
camera which basically gives us that
view projection matrix however when it
comes time to render we might render
different objects in our scene with
completely different shaders right so
it's not just a matter of saying okay
when we begin our scene let's take our
shader and then just submit the you know
upload this view projection matrix into
our shader has a uniform right that's
what we're going to do but and by the
way if you don't understand what
uniforms are anything like that you
should probably look into the shadows
video in OpenGL I actually don't
remember if I've done a proper video on
uniforms but if I haven't it's gonna
definitely come into the OpenGL series
very soon but anyway so we need to wait
to upload this into our shader however
we don't actually know like all of the
objects in our scene and what they're
gonna be rendered with right like as in
what I mean by that is what if we have a
sphere that's rendered with one
material and therefore uses one kind of
you know shader shader number one and
then we have a cube or like a background
or something like that
let's round it with a completely
different shader you know what do we do
well what actually needs to happen is
that view projection matrix needs to be
uploaded into both of those shaders
right but we haven't we don't know that
we're gonna submit this yet so we can't
actually do that so what begins scene
with the camera should actually do right
is it's not going to upload any uniforms
it's basically going to do one of two
things
it could just save a reference to the
camera right for later or like you know
if you were designing this in a
different way and you had like some kind
of uniform buffer to fill you could
actually copy this view projection
matrix into like a uniform buffer
essentially just do like a man copy or
something into a uniform buffer and then
when you actually start rendering with a
particular shader and theoretically your
render would batch together objects with
the same material by the way so with the
same shader so that you don't have to
kind of keep rebinding show to one
shadow to shadow one change to some of
that you just bunch adder one do all the
objects with that then bind chair to
render all the objects with bat shader
so when you bind the shader for the
first time you have that data inside
your Emperor that's the camera that's
the camera that belongs to the current
scene so what you do is you take the
view projection matrix from that and you
actually upload it into the shader right
as a uniform and that's done and then
you render all the objects and then you
bind it in different shader you do the
upload of the of the view projection
matrix and then you render all of the
objects right and that kind of gets
uploaded as a uniform as I mentioned
okay and that's kind of what begin scene
is supposed to do the responsibility is
let's grab this camera
let's either save the view projection
data from it or we can actually save a
reference to the actual camera usually
it's better if you're really being
optimal to just copy the data because
usually this will be submitted into a
like if you got a multi-threaded engine
it will be submitted into a render
submission queue taking a reference to
the camera is very dangerous because
before the render submission queue might
get evaluated you might have have
already changed the position of the
camera so it could because you know
typically a multi-threaded rendering is
one frame behind so anyway there's
there's kind of like
specifics to all of this that you know
it's
kind of like an asterisk it might not
work if you take a reference so it's
usually generally better to at that
point in time copy the data that you
want and then kind of put that into
basically your end a command queue
buffer but anyway so that's what begins
scene does right and then when we
actually do per object rendering that's
when we take the transformation matrix
of that object which is the model matrix
and upload that into the shader right so
what I'm trying to kind of iterate a
rewrite here is that when we begin a
scene we have a whole bunch of actual
shader uniforms that we need to set that
are part of our renderer so things like
camera things like the environment right
things like the lights they're not gonna
change on a per object basis but then we
have a bunch of uniforms again another
set of uniforms over here that are kind
of part of our material so what is this
object we're rendering right is it metal
is it plastic how shiny is that how much
should it reflect is it wood you know
what color is it all that kind of
information that is part of the material
so we have material uniforms which are
kind of per object or material because
again we might render several objects
with the same material and then we have
kind of our renderer uniforms right we
should basically you could say you're
seeing uniforms or there's a bunch of
different ways to call them right but
they're kind of handled by the renderer
whereas this is handled by the material
so this is kind of jumping ahead into
creating a whole material system and
doing all the fun stuff that we'll be
doing but hopefully you guys can kind of
see the bigger picture than me just
saying that cameras do this and that and
that's it okay so to summarize what we
need is a function called begin scene
that takes in a camera as a parameter
right it needs to get the view
projection from the camera which is
going to be the projection again which
is you know there's four of an aspect
ratio stuff and by the way it's it's
more than four of an aspect ratio it's
also the the minimum kind of call
distance and the maximum call distance
so we define basically clipping plans
that are like near and far clipping
planes so basically how close can an
object be to the camera before it gets
cold and how far away does an object
have to be from the camera for it not to
get rendered because as I said you know
this kind of creates a frost
like a view frustum which is kind of our
camera and then we need to define this
far plane which is this right and then
we also need to define this kind of near
plane so that's also what we need to do
for an actual projection matrix but we
have that view matrix is basically the
inverse of the camera's transform we
need to take that data we need to put it
into our end row when we start a new
scene right and then when something gets
submitted which right now and Hazel as
soon as it gets submitted it gets
rendered we actually need to see what
shader we're submitting that mesh or
that vertex array with right we when we
bind the shader for that we also need to
upload in this case both the view
projection and the actual model so
that's kind of the architecture of this
whole thing and n saying really does
nothing right still kind of does nothing
you could have it clear if you were
copying data you could have a clear the
data I don't know I wouldn't robably do
that in any case you could just have
like you could just keep track of
whether it whether you're inside a scene
or not so you could say like em you know
scene or whatever equals false or naal
or whatever and then that way if you try
and render something that hasn't you
haven't called begin scene or you call
begin scene and you call begins in again
without an scenic but like I said and
make sure that you it's like a little
protection thing that you do but
anything will have stuff in the future
obviously but not right now okay so
that's kind of the idea of this whole
camera system hopefully that makes sense
to you hopefully this is enough
information for you guys to try and
figure this out on your own before I
implement it in the next video but yeah
this is like a whole kind of this is the
whole basis for scenes and render isms
although that's that's very it's all
very exciting and you can see that it
leads to a really really cool system in
the future anyway hope you guys enjoy
this video if you didn't hit that like
button you can also help support the
series by going patient on accomplice
after Jerry you'll get access to source
code earlier and videos a week earlier
as I said in the future if you're
watching this live on youtube right now
publicly and you're not a patron you can
just see the next episode immediately
right now if you just go ahead and help
support a series okay so as I said next
time we're gonna actually dive into the
C++ code and the share
and everything like that and actually
make this happen we're gonna design an
orthographic camera not a perspective
camera because currently we're kind of
dealing with just 2d rendering and we
could do a perspective camera I'm not
sure but we will obviously eventually do
that anywhere when we have a 3d scene
and from there I'll probably want to
maybe I don't know it will branch off
into several things we might just talk
about them when we actually get there
and I'll try and kind of do something
that you guys want to see but
effectively we could continue on with 2d
or 2d rendering and actually maybe make
the camera controllable and also make it
so that we could render multiple objects
on the screen and then we could even
make it to the game or something like
that or we can just kind of do the base
level work for that and then just move
on straight to 3d depending on what you
guys want I mean I'm probably more keen
to do 3d to be honest because I love
that stuff but we will probably make
hazel more usable for actual QT Games
more quickly if we did this first so
it's kind of up to you guys to decide
anyway in the next episode we'll
implement the stuff make sure you have a
go on your own before you actually look
at the next episode I'll see you guys
later
good bye
[Music]